in ukraine the siege of a steel plant in
marijuana appears to be coming to an end
the facility has endured heavy
bombardment by russia for more than two
months now now this was the scene last
night as wounded ukrainian troops were
put on buses after emerging from the
plant
russian-backed separatists say more than
250 ukrainians had surrendered deborah
potter reports from marquis near the
russian border
the russian military took the wounded
ukrainian fighters to territory it
controls a prison exchange is being
negotiated while rescue attempts
continue for those still underground
as mario paul falls defiant ukrainian
soldiers celebrate a victory to the
north with a bold video announcing
we've reached the russian border mr
president
they've recaptured much of the land
surrounding the second largest city of
kharkiv
but it's still tense ukrainian soldiers
demand proof of this man's identity
suspicious of everyone
russian troops got to within less than a
mile here in derhachi despite their
retreat they can still inflict terrible
damage
this cultural center used as a
distribution hub for humanitarian aid
was hit twice in the past week mayor
vyacheslav zadorenko tells us and the
situation remains critical in four
nearby villages under russian control
they say they're liberating us from the
nazis the mayor said but in reality
they're liberating us from the peaceful
life we used to have
and that piece is still under threat
we've been hearing artillery all morning
they've pushed the russian forces back
but clearly not enough
the surreal sight of war in suburban
backyards remains as ukrainian tanks
rush to reposition themselves
and the hills reverberate with the grief
of women whose men died defending their
country
this
is no military funeral
julia los eva's husband was a 38 year
old truck driver
who'd never fought in his life
as for harkeef people are slowly
starting to return home but it's going
to take a while for the city to return
to normal tony
debra patta in ukraine for us deborah
thank you very much